tonight with a very special treat for
everyone they are coming back Final
Fantasy 7 is coming back they're doing
an HD remake or Final Fantasy 7 I don't
know how I feel about it we're reckless
tortuga I'm Jason I am Eric this is
hashtag news we're proud to announce
that Final Fantasy 7 remake is coming
first to PlayStation 4 today I was
talking about remaking Final Fantasy 7
on a modern console I love this game
when it came out in 1997 I spent maybe
40 hours trying to beat it it's one of
those games though that I kind of feel
like fits in 1997 I don't know how I'm
gonna feel about it now remake syndrome
man it is we got to remake everything
yeah
first it's Hollywood remaking movies now
we're doing it with video games it's
gonna be a little weird remaking this
game there's some odd moments in the
game there's like a cross-dressing
sequence that like at the time it was
fine like you're just like in a little
8-bit dress walking around but if you're
gonna do like a full-blown HD remake how
do you approach that you were
remembering this pretty well are you
looking forward to that moment dying
redundant HD look you spent five hours
playing a game you're gonna remember
things about it too that's all I'm
saying but that moment in particular
remembers everything it was weird it was
weird that it was like why am I putting
on a dress why is this turning me on how
every 17 so when you were 17 you spent
hours upon hours looking at this guy
crossdress and it burnt itself into your
memory I'm gonna have to go with yes and
breaking news
they just started so we'll see this four
to five years knowing 2020 yeah dead by
the time this game ever comes out so
it's fine how do you feel about this
game being remade tell us in the
comments below do you remember this
dress I need your help like help me so
I'm not alone in this
did that make an impression on you
having early age do you not get that out
of your memory you struggling with it
how's a bad one for me like and share
the video make sure to subscribe to new
media rockstars so you can see the rest
of the
coverage subscribe to our channel
reckless or tune guy and I have a wife
okay like I let's not let I don't want
this getting crazy in the comments I
shame crossdresser no maybe
[Music]